well is there like is there like a free
like does the free state project have
like land for like
organizational use so the free state
project again it's it's one percent of
the free state movement so the free
state project has like two employees and
a budget of like 200 000 a year okay
like it's a small organization the free
state movement owns like a billion
dollars worth of property in the state
and you know and the total
organizational budget of all the
different organizations is in the like
tens of millions or hundreds you know
it's a huge amount of what's happening
so are there real estate companies that
are owned by free staters that that
prioritize free standards that try to do
this kind of thing yeah they're not
explicitly under the auspices of the
free state project
is there a concern like the government
might come after people for sedition or
something
um
when's the last time that happened has
that happened
i mean i think after a long time
i think they're i think they're more
likely to come after you in like oblique
ways like you can look at how they've
targeted like ian freeman over some of
this crypto stuff free the crypto six by
the way um where like they're trying to
say he violated federal money
transmission laws i mean you can look at
how they're coming after me i'm being
sued by the federal government in civil
court um i think they're more likely to
do things in this way where
they don't have to make it explicitly
about what it's actually about
i came up with a little bit weird
spitballing ideas about secession or
what it might be and let me know what
you think about this that if the
government and people kind of laughed at
it because it's not a really well
thought out thing but if uh say new
hampshire were to secede but they set up
a smart contract or some sort of
automated system where if the united
states government federal government met
the terms of these secessionists they
would automatically be re-implemented
back into the
federal system yeah i i think that's a
very clever way to do it where you can
do it with these triggers that's the way
the free state project started by the
way um the free state project like it
wasn't like people were like new
hampshire's awesome let's move there it
started by there's a guy named jason
sorens he wrote this essay and uh
the opening of the essay was basically
the libertarian party is a failure the
liberty the notion of of the libertarian
party ever achieving its agenda in my
lifetime is like literally hopeless you
know i bet all this money that that will
never happen he made this 20-year
prediction 20 years ago it came true
just very recently he was completely
correct
and he said that like but there are
enough libertarians in the country that
if we concentrated we could actually
achieve our agenda and the way that
started was people signed an assurance
contract like a kickstarter and so it
started with 5 000 people saying well
we're not sure where we're going to move
but we'll all move to the place that we
agree on and then we'll continue to keep
the movement going from there so there's
this whole selection process
like wyoming was the second state and
alaska i think was the third and they
went through i mean there was a longer
list but that's the way it came out new
hampshire came in first wyoming came in
second and alaska came in third where
they went through and debated all the
possible states and a key target was low
population right new hampshire only has
a million people right um so that's part
of why we're able to have such an
outsized effect with only you know 10
000
you know or so
so if
a million in one people move to new
hampshire and then you vote you get
exactly what you want yeah exactly i
don't think you need anywhere near that
number and i was i was talking to lydia
about this about like you know a big
part of libertarians tend to be
either like they tend to be
independently minded right yeah and so
they they tend to do commit the typical
mind fallacy and model other people as
independently minded it's a big part of
why the libertarian party is such a
failure they're like people make their
decisions as independent rational
animals and they consider the policy and
then our policies are better so they'll
vote for us and it is like the most
absolutely wrong model of how people
actually decide things most people are
agreeable they decide things to feel
like they're being agreeable to feel
like they're getting along and going
along and this is what other people
believe and so when you have it's a is
another way of uh
nasting to labs tyranny of the minority
if you have this small minority of
people that are extremely vocal about
what they believe they pull a ton of
these agreeable people to their
positions and it's a big part of how
we're succeeding it's even how the
libertarians in new hampshire are making
the republican party more
libertarian is because they go in and
they're republicans now and they're
advocating these really libertarian
positions and so they've pulled these
like you know these like trumpian
conservative types to be much more
libertarian because they're there
they're republicans and they're being
loud about what they believe what what's
like a state what's the state budget
like i feel like we could bring billions
of dollars in industry into that state
there's so much money in defecting
there's so much money in for one country
or one state to defect from the not just
the us regime but the the global regime
uh in terms of the way that it shuts
down creative entrepreneurship and all
kinds of other things i i think
you know new hampshire is
not the best choice i think west
virginia is is better oh you're
landlocked though i mean if we're if
we're role-playing all this out that's
true yeah unlocked is bad but the issue
is new hampshire's blue i'm looking at
their election results i i think that is
a res so new hampshire is a republican
governor 60 of the republican executive
council which is this organ that other
people don't have but it's part of the
executive body republican senate
republican state legislature the entire
state government is red so it was just
like an anti-trump recoil maybe
a lot of new hampshire conservatives do
not do not like trump new hampshire's
like traveling back in time this is one
of the weirdest parts where it's like
they're like decorum and the process and
and rational and we're going to debate
things and like let's all get along and
so so the kind of like brash style that
trump had was very off-putting to a lot
of yeah that's true
and and i mentioned it all the time like
regular people were like i don't like
the way he talks that hurts them it
helped him in a lot of ways but you know
i look landlocked is a big issue but
it's actually
the other issue is who you're surrounded
by in new hampshire so i had this debate
with luke all the time he's like new
hampshire's the best and i'm like yeah
but who's look what you're surrounded by
canada
and then you got uh massachusetts you
got what's the vermont
vermont's not bad yeah i i i actually
think this helps in terms of
acceleration because the truth is like
it's awesome we have people move from
california and all over the all over the
country but the truth is more people
move from closer nearby right and so if
you're in a place like wyoming
where where are you pulling people from
it's a big everywhere right right yeah
if you're in new hampshire it's you know
there's a lot of libertarians in
massachusetts and in new york there's a
lot of libertarians in new york exactly
and it's not that hard to move from
those places uh to new hampshire it's a
little more palatable so i actually
think it's it's been a good choice by
the movement to be in this population
center all right i agree with you now
yes okay and look you know we're going
to be the hong kong of america so as
america turns into china we're going to
become
hong kong with more guns okay that's
what new hampshire is going to become
it's actually very valuable to be on the
border with canada yeah
especially if global warming is real
canada is going to be a tropical
paradise maybe not tropical subtropical
it's going to be a beautiful beautiful
country again even the the the ipcc like
consensus estimate
is like what it's like two to three
degrees c right like it's not it's
things would change but they wouldn't i
hear you got you guys looking for trade
black flies in new hampshire
uh
i i know we're we don't have one of the
most common types of mosquitoes they
don't come that far north oh ah but you
got black flies
pretty short probably so
i know in northern maine so we were
actually looking for a bunch of places
to set up like outside of cities and i
was like maine you know maybe but maine
is insanely expensive and there's like
there's cheaper areas there's limited
infrastructure it's because all the
really rich people go to like the shores
of portland of of maine to get away and
it's just like
yeah you got to be pretty well off for
the most part and i was looking at
property and comparing it you know
identical infrastructure substantially
cheaper in the west virginia area than
basically anywhere else
i've been thinking about setting up um
like a university for uh scientists that
want to learn how to use to make
graphene because i don't know if you're
familiar much with graphene but it's
gonna be a 21st century steel we're
right about 2029 we're gonna start to
see inflex um and i was gonna do it
nationally like do it in chicago get the
federal funds to fund it build an
american thing that we manage for 15
years and show all these americans that
get two weeks for free with their tax
money to come and learn how to use it
and then all the graphing we produce is
free for all americans forever and then
after 15 years it becomes a utility and
we just produce and use free and it's
like space elevator travel but we could
do it on a
on a state level makes a lot more sense
yeah let's do it new hampshire graphing
capital of the world there you go it's
gonna happen you gotta get you gotta get
some industry to come in and um i gotta
be honest there's a lot of very very
very wealthy people and i'm surprised we
don't see more of this i am surprised
more wealthy people don't try to defect
but i mean new hampshire is like that's
a thing it has like a small population
and in some ways it can feel rural but
it really has everything it has a huge
tech industry the average income in new
hampshire is like in the top five for
states like it's if the median income is
like 75 000 a year or something
constitutional carry oh yeah
constitutional carry stand your ground
castle doctrine we've got like the best
gun gun laws what's this what's your
state motto
live free or die wow
maybe we should slowly start moving
production up to new hampshire yeah and
we mean it like seriously
people mean it it's like people have a
liberty and this is again part of why
the state was chosen like people have a
natural libertarian bias they don't want
to be in your business they don't want
to bother you um
new hampshire had the highest vote
percentage for ron paul in in 2012 right
like of of any state in the country i
mean there is a there was a natural
libertarian leaning to the population
well there you go yeah what the future
is what if we like lived there three
months out of the year or something only
in the winter
yeah only in the deepest winter
well i like that we're centralized right
now we're closer to dc it's it's but i
don't know if that is going to be
necessary i think like
whether you would be happy in new
hampshire like listening to this
conversation is like reading a dating
profile and deciding if someone is going
to be your wife okay or husband like
this is a dating profile this is like do
i want to go on a date with this person
it's not do i want to marry them so you
don't have to be convinced that new
hampshire is the best place for you what
you have to do is be curious and then
the next step is you come for a visit
you come check it out you come to pork
fest this summer you buy your tickets
tonight because it's going to sell out
you come you come to liberty forum in
the fall which is not quite as as laid
back as as uh pork fest but it's for
like the people who want to be like i
want to get stuff done i'm a serious
person at new hampshire
nhlibertyforum.com you can buy tickets
right now come for a visit anytime the
fsp will literally be like your personal
tour guide we'll plug you into all the
secret stuff that's not available online
if you contact us we'll teach you about
the secret club and there's a public
calendar but there's also stuff that's
like not on the calendar so you got to
come for a visit you got to get in touch
with us and we'll let you check out the
state and then you can decide if that's
a place you want to be
i don't you know
i don't care if it's west virginia or
wyoming or new hampshire the idea of
like people coming together and so for
at this point it's like the free state
project's been around so long and new
hampshire probably does make the most
sense just based on what's what's
already built and it's you know its
foundation and
man new hampshire is a pretty free place
i see you know luke firing the
flamethrower yeah
he fired at a pork fest this summer
that's a great video
the idea that we could effect government
change is very exhilarating
as an american i'm like as if that
should be anything but the norm but
i don't know what's like the libertarian
political movement in new hampshire
right now
in the government there yeah so and let
me first say that like i agree with you
completely like i i
hated
voting when i lived in philadelphia i
basically didn't do it i did it like
begrudgingly because you know your
friends are like you have to vote jeremy
you're don't be a bad person
um uh and i'm like happy to vote every
time i go in to vote every single
election i can vote for someone who i
feel like shares my values and wants the
world to be the kind of way that i want
the world to be and that does feel it's
the first time that voting has like felt
good to me in a very long time since
maybe when i was in my early 20s and
actually believed it in a more you know
genuine form um so it's ended a lot of
that cynicism uh and
libertarians run for every kind of
office position office they run as
democrats they run as republicans they
run as libertarians most of them do get
elected as republicans but they get
elected under every party
you only send a libertarian
candidate to congress i agree
i think i think one of the most
important things is to have like a duly
elected like formally elected
libertarian go there
probably talks with republicans i'd
imagine yeah i mean i i i would love to
see it i mean i think it's i do think
it's really hard to win third party and
i'm looking i'm i'm a supporter of the
like the libertarian party seems like
it's becoming more libertarian again
with you know with the mises caucus and
dave smith he's awesome and all of these
people who are like you're really giving
this full-throated support for
libertarianism rather than like the woke
neo-liberal party or like whatever it
had become um but i think it is really
hard to win as a third party um i think
that you have whatever that law is like
duverger's law or whatever that like you
know just like it everything trends
towards two parties and so it's really
hard to win as a third party um i you
know so i would love it if a libert you
know i would love it if a libertarian
party candidate could win i really just
want libertarians to win i don't care
what letter is next to your name yeah
like a libertarian government governor
yeah the there is um so the current he
was a fat past candidate for governor
and he's currently the head of the
school
place organization what's the branch of
government department of the school
department education state yeah
yeah i clearly attended we're deep right
now yeah uh uh anyway he's like super
he's like very libertarian uh and he's
he's decently likely to be the next uh
governor so the current governor is like
he's like libertarian financially but
he's like not as libertarian on other
policies one as a republican win and
then immediately announce you're in the
libertarian party that so we had
republicans do that that's how new
hampshire had three um
libertarians in the state legislature
like four years ago and that was exactly
what they did that's how they did it
they ran us republicans one and they
were like all right we're libertarians
yep
the libertarian party is so wacky though
that's the problem
it's the only way
the libertarian party likes to tout
these candidates they're like oh we have
these there's lit they've literally
never won a three-way race literally
never all of their candidates that are
in the state legislature either one and
defected defected whatever changed
parties or they ran a two-party race so
like they have marshall burt and wyoming
he ran libertarian against democrat
without a republican in the race and was
and was able to win
so if you can somehow get it down to two
parties i think the libertarian party
could win and i think it'd be great if
libertarians could run under the
libertarian party like the libertarian
party platform is more libertarian than
the republican platform although in new
hampshire this is another way that
libertarians they're so
i gotta say if you've never been part of
a cabal
you need to get a cabal like cabals are
awesome they're really fun right uh and
so then one of the ways they win is like
they go in and they write the republican
platforms like the republican platform
you can look it up for the republican
platform of new hampshire not nationally
it's like pretty libertarian and if you
look at the scores of state reps the
libertarian ones do better because the
libertarians wrote the republican
platform for the mo not entirely there's
clearly some things in there they didn't
get that they would have left out but
it's much more libertarian than most
republican clubs i think we could set up
uh free software machine learning
algorithms to advise the governor if not
i wouldn't want to act as a governor
because i want a human to make the final
call but i want people to be able to
watch the advisement that the governor
is receiving and then i mean we could
really
create like an art project
yeah i mean i'm actually not fully
getting this idea but like if we need
some sort having one human controlling
all this power is insane to me and i
would love to disperse the power of the
governor amongst many people i don't
know if that's functional for like
split-second decisions but usually
governors don't have to make those
that's like the president
so
but i'm also interested in utilizing ai
to ease the the political thing like you
said you hate voting no one wants to
deal with that we send representatives
because we have to because it's the
least worst system
so maybe what if there was a system
where
machine learning just figured out what
people tended towards i'm not saying
this is a good thing i'm saying what
would a system be like if you know
youtube says like man people sure do
love clicking on you know boobs or
whatever so they show you more and more
of that stuff then eventually a human
has to intervene because people are
complaining like this goes against their
values what would a government
government be like if laws changed based
on how people reacted to the system in
place so it was amorphous almost
depends on how good the system is like i
mean i think i'm socialist
yeah i mean i'm like yeah i'm i'm like
relatively anti-democratic and like
anti-uh you know populist i think like
generally the more democratic we've
become the less libertarian we've become
one of my unpopular beliefs among
libertarians i'll say it now because i
am one of those highly disagreeable
types who says these things anyway it's
like i think libertarians need to face
the fact that most people aren't
libertarian most people don't want to be
libertarian most people
don't actually like freedom and personal
responsibility
and individual choice but they don't so
you need to level up the free state
project and not just attract
libertarians but also attract people by
saying if you want to be a sheep in the
flock protected by a strong sheepdog and
a shepherd
new hampshire's place for you just do as
you're told vote the way we tell you and
we'll keep you safe yeah i i i think
there is a way that happens and almost
kind of already does though not quite
that explicitly but there are all kinds
of libertarians that are like large
employers right and and a large employer
has the chance to kind of like they are
kind of playing that role not always but
you know they're giving you a job but
they also have this chance to kind of
push political perspectives they have
this chance to influence the way that
you think and if you're agreeable you
kind of am my boss is good to me and so
on and so when you have these
libertarians and this is part of this is
what the libertarian party doesn't
understand what i think the free state
movement does whether implicitly or
explicitly is like the way you actually
change people's minds is you become an
accomplished person you attain status in
your community by being a good person by
being a good father by being a
contributor by being a volunteer by
being successful you know um
by having your life together and when
you do all of those things people look
up to you and then people copy and adapt
your values and what you believe because
they see well look at that person look
at how he is or she is and i want to be
more like that have you considered just
um using your funding for propaganda
campaigns to just trick people into
supporting you
well i mean again people do the
libertarians do run under every party we
don't have that much money our money is
going to get people here we're the bus
right so mom you know get people on the
bus but so i remember reading about like
all these rich people got a cruise ship
so they could do weird stuff in
international waters that was illegal
for like their businesses or something
where are the billionaires to be like
let's just go to new hampshire and fund
this so that we can have laissez faire
puerto rico yeah a lot of them went to
puerto rico after the hurricane and
started to rebuild a new utopian bitcoin
utopia so i heard that's the last i
heard of it a billionaire could conquer
new hampshire as it were you know
come with massive funding like
everything you mentioned about the low
population and people you like okay for
all billionaires listening uh please
contact me
2020 tax revenue was 800 million in in
this state i mean we could bring
billions and especially with the amount
of money that's been printed lately
yikes geez we could bring a lot of money
into that state it's not really about
the money though it's about what we
produce the production well really all
that needs to happen is employers need
to relocate to the state
you if you've got you know any amount of
employers and you relocate to new
hampshire you bring those employee
employees with you not an easy thing for
everybody but if you can do that that
not only brings more money to the state
but it brings those people and their
taxes and and it and it just makes the
economy of new hampshire better wouldn't
it be funny like just imagine
you know 100 years from now you look at
a topographical map of the united states
and it's like everything looks kind of
the same but new hampshire is a is a
massive megatropolis with like playing
cards oh that's the future have you ever
seen uh this i love this video it's from
i think it's called gray still plays is
that the guy the youtuber
this guy he was playing a game called
city state i think it's called
and you you basically are building a
city state you can choose to have taxes
low taxes high taxes you can choose to
regulate or deregulate and things like
that and so he decides to play this game
where he's like i'm just gonna it's
gonna be anarchy it's gonna be whatever
i don't care no rules no taxes
and what he thought was gonna happen was
it was gonna be poverty and chaos
and it's a hilarious video because he's
like what's happening and like there's
no poor there's zero poverty everyone's
wealthy ski resorts keep popping up all
over the place and he's like what and
all he did was say no taxes no
government no intervention and it just
everyone lived in luxury city state
two's out by the way awesome game shout
out to raptor games on youtube well i i
think this is another thing that some
libertarians can miss because like most
everyone lives in luxury now
right like seriously i'm not trying to
say they're psychologically healthy or
they're physically healthy but in terms
of like if you could work like a minimum
wage job and in terms of what you have
available to you in terms of like
quality food
technology all these things it is
a better life than most people have had
throughout history the difference is
that human beings some a lot of
libertarians don't feel this way but
most other people do
they have they experience a psychic pain
when other people have more than them
they literally like they they do
they this is part of what libertarian
libertarians tend to not experience this
a lot of them don't believe me when i
say this but that's why that's what so
much of this stuff is about that's what
the green new deal is about that's why
socialists don't actually care if their
policies would make people worse off
because it's about bringing people
closer together because they're pained
by the fact that other people have that
why do so many people hate why do so
many environmentalists hate elon musk
who's doing more to make the world green
than like anyone else because he's
really rich yeah right why is there so
much hatred for jeff bezos who again
gives lots of 15 20 an hour jobs that
anyone can go and get right
because he's really rich and like there
are a lot of people i don't have this
feeling i don't have it myself but there
are a lot of people who just have that
feeling and simply the distance
in resources
makes that person back so the envy i
guess is work yeah maybe i used to feel
that one of the great tables in la and
i'd wait on i was just telling the story
with you guys last couple nights ago
last night and i would just get it i'd
be like gosh i wish i could not have to
work in the middle of the day and go
walk my dog with my sandals on and eat
30 meals
every day five days a week
and i just go about my business thinking
like i want that'd be awesome
to get back to it you know just dealing
with my reality but i felt it you know
it's not as much anymore but you know
i've also done more that i'm proud of so
that's part of it
yeah that's socialism it's envy uh
people not realizing that uh you have
better dental care today than
rockefeller did
he's got the this this massive wealth
the wealthiest guy and you can get
better you got air conditioning he
didn't you've got a refrigerator luxury
items we've got a t you got a tv you got
a big screen tv you got vr headsets for
a couple hundred bucks
you know i was talking about this a
while back
someone when someone said something to
occupy they were like you know we're the
first generation that's gonna be worse
off than our parents
our parents generation and i was like my
dad didn't have a tv or a phone
like because they were not it was like
tvs were expensive
now people got tvs in their pockets
and you got to pay the bill for that
like if you if you could take this
device back in history and it still
somehow worked it would be worth like
all the world's wealth like all of it or
half of it or something like tremendous
if you downloaded the contents of
wikipedia onto this device
and had like a charging cable and a
battery pack that could easily recharge
it because or you know just a wall
charger you brought it back 50 years
it'd be worth 100 trillion dollars
because it's it's now to be fair future
information is worth a different moment
but like let's say
all it had
let's say you downloaded wikipedia's
a wikipedia database an encyclopedic
database from 1970 identical information
to what that is time nothing beyond
their their level of knowledge the
device would still be worth billions of
dollars trillions yeah yeah trillions
because they could be like i can pull up
all of the information we currently know
of 1970 and no one else can
oh yeah governments would look for it it
would be oh yeah it's it's fascinating i
love like these the shows the superhero
shows you know heroes did it where they
like you know how do you handle people
with powers and people who don't so in
like x-men they have the mutant registry
act because they're like this is
dangerous these mutants
and i i think about
there's this uh
this is a common trope in sci-fi and i
think it's just often said the reason
why aliens would not give humans
technology is what do you think they
would do with it they'd wage war what do
you think would happen if you went to uh
um you know a village in africa and said
here's a stockpile of you know m16s or
something and crates full of ammo they
would be like we're going to use it to
empower ourselves and we're going to you
know
take care of our enemies so what happens
in the u.s or i should say in the world
is that typically all this technology
arises
simultaneously
in different ways so you do end up with
world war and conflict in crisis but for
the most part we're always kind of you
know at an equal level what would happen
if you came and gave
this this power of knowledge to a a you
know a prior generation
to us it's a cell phone we look at
pictures of cats and we argue with
strangers on the internet
back then it would be one of the most
powerful weapons the world had ever seen
the fact that someone could be like i
can know everything humans can know like
that yeah the envy thing seems like an
emergent phenomenon because obviously
people have enough i mean we have enough
to become super gods if any one person
wanted to study everything on the
internet and remember it memorize it
you'd be
yeah i mean i think it's driven by
evolution like no one wants to be like
we've always lived in some sort of
social hierarchies throughout our
evolution and and everyone wants to be
at the top and no one wants to feel like
they're at the bottom and so it's for
the people at the bottom of any sort of
hierarchy they want to gang up on and
take down the
the person at the top i think it's i
think it's something that's been i think
primates do it i think all kinds of
other social animals uh do it i think
you know another point of evidence in
this favor is like if you look at
happiness research
people in countries that are much poorer
than the us like aren't substantially
less happy than than people in the us
like the distribution of happiness is
like pretty similar well because it's
not really about
how well off you i mean it plays a role
i'm not saying they're literally the
same but it's much more about you hey if
you're doing well in society this is
also why there's you see this research
sometimes it's like oh you know um
if everyone made 80 000 a year they'd be
happy look at this research once once
people make this amount of money they're
much happier it's not about the money
it's not about the resources it's about
that once you're at that a certain level
you you experience happiness from being
you know having achieved this success
that that distances you from others and
this is like a kind of like cold and
uncomfortable way to talk about but i
think it's the truth i will i will say
though having a little bit of money have
enough money to eat whatever i want
whenever i want and to sleep as late as
i want is life-changing yes when you're
talking about like abject poverty like
there's clear differences there so i'm
not i'm not talking about like quite at
that level there are clear differences i
once read that a paraplegic a year after
their accident and a lottery winner a
year after winning register the same
levels of happiness yeah we have we we
experienced these hedonic adjustments
jonathan haight has some really good
research on this topic
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast if you want to
see the full show come back to this
channel youtube.com tim cast irl monday
through friday at 8 pm where you can
leave comments and super chat and we
actually will read your comments on the
show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else go to timcast.com
become a member and we even have full
bonus episodes thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time